everyone we are at the tangle palace
cafe here in Toronto we were sent here
by friend of the channel and team member
Jennifer price who on her channel
challenged people to go to a new coffee
shop when she challenged people in
Toronto and city city to go to this
place and Jason and I are both from oh
this is jason you guys are Jason Susan
Hayden you guys know Hayden Jase and I
are both in Toronto and have never been
here you've been here was never been
here so we're grabbing some Hayden's
never been here we're grabbing some
drinks Jason's got a coffee we Hayden's
got a hot chocolate and I've got a
coffee and we're going to enjoy this new
cafe look at the official cheers Cheers
yummy it's like a really good com yeah
me yeah this peacock i gotta agree it's
good with cream so I wanted to extend
the challenge to you guys to go find a
cafe or coffee shop in your local area
that you've never been to post a video
and if you do i'm gonna make a playlist
on my channel me that will highlight
that will highlight your videos so if
you want to have a video on one of my
playlist go to a new cafe
never been to in your city make a video
about it and and post it up and i will
add it to the playlist alright we're
going to enjoy we're going to have our
meeting I'm gonna have our coffee
remember to me remember to believe oh my
god